[Music]
on this saturday night deadly twisters
dozens are feared dead after multiple
tornadoes tear through several u.s
states the level of devastation is
unlike anything i've ever seen hospitals
brace for omicron we'll very likely all
get exposed to this at some point the
impact of the new variant in canada
looming trade war we did our part now do
yours the fight over electric vehicle
tax credits and just google it the top
search trends of 2021
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with what could be
one of the deadliest tornado events in
u.s history this is the devastating
aftermath in mayfield kentucky one of
the hardest hit areas severe weather
ripped through at least five states
overnight it spawned several twisters
one of them is believed to have touched
down for more than 300 kilometers it's
being dubbed the quad state tornado
ripping across four states in four hours
potentially breaking a 96 year old
record
under the cloak of darkness ominous
sirens signaled the catastrophe and
glimpses of the monstrous tornado were
caught when lightning lit up the sky
at least 70 people are feared dead in
kentucky alone jennifer johnson has our
top story tonight
there is little left of the town of
mayfield kentucky what's being described
as one of the worst tornadoes to ever
hit the state ripped through the
community that's home to fewer than 10
thousand people search and rescue teams
and townspeople are digging through the
remains of leveled buildings including a
local candle factory where mass
casualties are expected it is
indescribable the level of devastation
is unlike anything i have ever seen
please know that there are a lot of
families that need your prayers prayers
that somebody may be found
or prayers to help them through the
grieving process
the governor fears over a hundred people
could be dead the national guard has
been deployed to aid in recovery efforts
police and firefighters are desperate
for help in addition to
the fire station our police station
was destroyed in the storm there are
people coming from all over the country
here right now
we are very blessed
air sirens warn people the tornadoes
were coming but one stayed on the ground
through kentucky and into other states
for over 365 kilometers destroying
virtually everything in its path the
violent storms tore through a whole
section of the country from arkansas to
illinois
a part of this amazon facility in
edwardsville illinois came down trapping
several workers and killing at least two
when i went around to the back area that
was completely destroyed it looked like
somebody just blew out the whole back
area it was debris all across the lake
the power losses down
there were fatalities too with this
monette arkansas nursing home after a
tornado hit it trapping at least 20
elderly residents inside they could not
do anything but just they're at the
mercy of the staff and god above to what
happens to it breaks my heart to see
that in middle and western tennessee
several other tornadoes destroyed town
after town it's devastating to see stuff
that i grew up with i mean it's just
gone
president joe biden was briefed on the
massive destruction the federal
government will do everything
everything it can possibly do to help
recovery efforts will take several more
days and the death toll is expected to
keep rising
jennifer johnson global news washington
let's bring in meteorologist yvonne
shell who's keeping an eye on this storm
system yvonne where is it headed next it
continues to track with widespread
thunderstorms and it is moving from west
to east and we can see that line on the
satellite and radar and the potential
and risk for severe weather will
continue in the united states honing on
in though on eastern canada we are
seeing the potential from the same
system it is connected in a cold front
that's sweeping across the area for
southern ontario now the biggest threat
and concern will be wind gusts between
90 and potentially up to 110 kilometers
per hour on those gusts damaging and the
potential for power outages also for
eastern canada and stretching in towards
atlantic canada rain will pick up up to
50 millimeters and the risk of freezing
rain paired with very windy conditions
so much of eastern canada is going to be
impacted and the potential and risk will
be the threat of very windy conditions
robin okay vaughn we'll continue to
monitor the situation thanks for that
turning now to the pandemic and the
surge in covet 19 cases across the
country today ontario is reporting more
than 1600 new cases that's the highest
daily count in nearly seven months
dozens of those cases are confirmed to
be the new omicron variant and officials
say they're investigating other possible
cases as brittany rosen explains the new
highly transmissible variant has health
care workers across the country
concerned
i am concerned about the rise in omicron
across ontario i want to strongly urge
everyone to get vaccinated and to get
your booster dose as soon as you are
eligible to do so amid rising case
counts ontario is taking swift steps to
vaccinate the province against covet 19
expanding third dose eligibility to
those 18 and over beginning january 4th
we should really be doing that sooner
than january 4th
officials predict omicron will soon
overtake delta as the dominant variant
its ability to infect people with two or
three doses of the vaccine means no one
is completely out of harm's way it's not
nice to talk about it but that's just
the reality we'll very likely all get
exposed to this at some point
in the hospitals doctors are bracing for
a surge of omicron cases over the
holidays one thing that worries me is
that there's huge overcrowd outbreaks in
london and kingston both college towns
when school is out they're going to
bring it home to parents and family
members while what we know about omicron
is still under the microscope there's
not only concern about the implications
of a potential spike in hospitalizations
but how exhausted workers will continue
to fight the battle on the front lines i
feel numb at this point it's gone on for
so long the pandemic we're nearing the
two-year mark nurses sarah fong and amy
archibald varley say hospital staff are
burned out and more are leaving the
profession each day we're scared for
what health care is going to look like
in 2022 we can't lose any more nurses
and
it's it's really scary that we're not
over this
amid the holiday season many in the
healthcare sector are urging families to
keep gathering small how many times do
we have to fall into the same trap we've
already seen big omicron outbreaks even
here in canada
with those types of events like you
could we can prevent that from happening
somber words for canadians heading into
another christmas under the gloom of the
pandemic
brittany rosen global news toronto
nova scotia is seeing a significant
spike in new covet 19 cases the province
is reporting 129 confirmed cases today
the bulk of them are in the central and
eastern health zones officials were not
able to confirm if they're linked to an
outbreak at st francis xavier university
so far there are more than 110 cases
connected to the school it's believed
the virus spread at recent graduation
events
canada could be on the verge of another
trade war with the u.s ottawa is
threatening a retaliatory barrage of
targeted tariffs if washington moves
forward with a controversial electric
vehicle tax credit michael couture
breaks down the protectionist policy and
how canada plans to respond
we're going to talk about that
to some extent
it was discussed in the oval office last
month but canada is turning up the
pressure on the u.s pushing for a
pullback on the protectionist american
electric vehicle tax late friday deputy
prime minister christian freeland and
international trade minister mary ing
wrote a letter to a number of
influential american senators saying if
the proposed tax becomes law
canada will impose retaliatory tariffs
on the u.s it will include the auto
center but it will include other
other areas of u.s
exports to canada that will face
increased tariffs
many believe the u.s tax violates the
terms of the trilateral trade agreement
known as c-o-s-m-a
it's an incentive to consumers to buy
american-built electric cars
three-quarters of canadian-built cars go
to the u.s so that incentive would make
our cars more expensive
it's you know potentially catastrophic
for our industry
would you go to a dealership and buy the
same car for twelve thousand five
hundred more
to make
some other countries citizens happy i
mean i wouldn't the dispute brings back
bad memories of the tit for tat tariff
battle of 2018 when then president
donald trump imposed tariffs on canadian
steel and aluminum our government
responded with targeted taxes on things
like playing cards and whiskey a year
later both sides ended the tariffs
however now
canada is preparing another list while
canada doesn't want to be here
we certainly need to
be prepared to defend our national
interest and that's what this is about
it's also about the biden
administration's attempt to keep the
american public happy by keeping jobs in
the u.s
some observers believe protectionist
policies
should be bilateral certainly against
china and unfair traders we need to be
protectionists but between canada and
the us we have two countries that are
trying to do the right thing and it
doesn't make sense if to just have
blanket protection this has to be
strategic part of that strategy is to
continue engaging with american
lawmakers another canadian delegation
will be heading down to washington next
week hoping to convince the bind
administration to back down on this bill
robin mike lucatour in ottawa thanks
mike
global affairs minister melanie jolie
and international development minister
harji sudden are in england this weekend
for a g7 meeting the host country is
looking for a show of unity against
global aggressors the uk is seeking
elusive consensus from the wealthy
nations in response to what it calls
malign behavior by russia there's
concern that a buildup of russian troops
near the border with ukraine may be
signaling an invasion moscow denies any
plans to
attack a former canadian ambassador to
china is calling for a clearer policy
with beijing gisen jacques says canada's
diplomatic boycott of the upcoming
winter games is the right call but
firmer action is needed and that's this
week's topic on the west block with
abigail beeman abigail
robin the speech from the throne
mentioned deepening partnerships in the
quote indo-pacific a former canadian
ambassador to china told the west block
he's itching to hear more on a
canada-china policy and soon what we
have heard that
this new indo-pacific strategy
will cover china
but that in fact the the what i've heard
is that the policy on china will be
flexible
and
maybe
not very explicit and i'm a bit puzzled
by this because it's always clearer for
everyone for for diplomats for
politicians and for our allies to know
exactly where we stand gisen jacques
says at a minimum the china strategy
needs to be firmer with security an
important angle he says we need to work
on a common strategy with five eyes
allies to oppose what he calls the dark
side of china as for the diplomatic
boycott of the upcoming olympic games
saint jacques believes canada's move
plays catch-up but it may be the only
option left at this point without
penalizing athletes and he hopes more
countries get on board with that same
diplomatic boycott
with news our current ambassador to
china dominic barton is stepping down
i also asked the former ambassador what
kind of attributes the next person in
the role should have you can hear our
full conversation including his thoughts
on huawei and potential retaliation from
china that's all on the west block
sunday robin abigail beeman in ottawa
thanks abigail
and those calls are growing for an
international boycott of the games in
beijing today protesters gathered
outside the swiss headquarters of the
international olympic committee
[Music]
two tibetan students chained themselves
to the olympic greens as part of a
demonstration against what they call
beijing's abuse of human rights the
activists are demanding all countries
withdraw from the event they've dubbed
the genocide games
still ahead the poisonous drugs fueling
british columbia's opioid crisis
the heartbreaking toll from the toxic
drug crisis in this country keeps
accelerating british columbia's chief
coroner says october was the worst month
yet in the province's nearly six-year
overdose crisis even though the year
isn't over 2021 is already the deadliest
on record global bc's rumina deaf spoke
to one man about his road to recovery
and what he says needs to be done to
save more lives
this is what freedom looks like
60 days clean
kevin tierney is about to set eyes on
his new home this is wonderful
this is absolutely amazing
you can feel the weight of his gratitude
as he remembers his past have you
overdosed
uh six times
six times yeah
so
i consider myself very lucky just to be
alive today alive but grieving the loss
of most of his friends
poisonous street drugs killing people
faster than the rate of covet 19. today
we will lose six more people tomorrow we
will lose six more people and by
christmas we'll have lost another 40 or
50 members of our communities and that
is just not acceptable any longer more
than 200 dead in october alone a grim
record for b.c the first 10 months of
2021 more deadly than all of last year
the chief coroner clearly frustrated
with the lack of safe supply because not
all doctors are on board plus the pace
of government action given where in year
six of a public health emergency more
than 8
300 victims and counting the
increased toxicity of the drugs
illicit street drugs have outpaced
the historic rate of expansion of our
addictions care system the greatest
obstacle a lack of long-term stable
housing says tierney who's been in and
out of drug treatment and in and out of
jail the 40 year old has spent 10 years
of his adult life behind bars
being released from from jail and back
into the community there is not enough
support for that transition most guys
get released with less than five hundred
dollars in their pocket and nowhere to
go so what's different this time after
nine months in prison for property
crimes tierney went straight from jail
into drug treatment at phoenix society
next step transitional housing for two
years
for me this little apartment is
everything tierney has resuscitated his
life he's already registered for school
with ambition of going into the trades
from hopeless to hopeful he's living
proof a big piece of why i'm trying so
hard is like so my poor mother doesn't
have to bury her son
romina daya global news vancouver
still ahead new zealand's crackdown on
smoking and how it compares to canada's
laws
you're watching global national
new zealand is taking a bold step to get
smokers to butt out more than 11 of the
country's adults light up daily and on
average they start smoking at around age
15 but a new government plan aims to
break the habit for the generations to
come mike trolley explains
in new zealand the cigarette's days are
numbered this is an important milestone
in the history of tobacco control if
passed a new law will make it illegal
for anyone currently under the age of 14
to ever buy cigarettes
every year the minimum age to buy
cigarettes will rise and for those who
can still legally smoke they'll find
cigarettes with reduced nicotine levels
and fewer places to buy them we need a
dramatic shift in the environment to
denormalise smoking the crackdown was
made in part because cessation programs
weren't having the impact the medical
community had hoped for 13 percent of
new zealanders are regular smokers the
same rate found in canada and while new
zealand hopes to reduce its smoking rate
to five percent by 2025 canada's goal is
five percent by 2035. what new zealand
is showing here is that we can do better
and we can do faster um and these are
the the processes that that that need to
be put in place uh to be able to do that
and we need to start those discussions
around how to do that here um right away
but how to make it work is the big
question critics in new zealand suggest
black market cigarettes will thrive in
organized crime along with it in canada
another roadblock would be convincing
indigenous peoples to abandon tobacco
which has traditionally been
incorporated into some rituals and
ceremonies and neither of those issues
compare with the argument about civil
liberties so that's part of the social
debate is it's a fair thing to hone in
on because if a person says this is my
body
this is my house and i live in this
house and i choose to smoke
it's a tough argument to say you're not
allowed to do that new zealanders are
used to bold moves by their government
which decided to ban assault rifles two
years ago will they accept being told to
butt out would canadians or is this
legislation that's gone too far
mike dralet global news toronto
up next were you more interested in alec
baldwin or kyle rittenhouse we'll
explain when global national continues
we are in the final days of 2021 and
what a year it has been from the chaos
following the taliban takeover of
afghanistan to the pandemic that just
won't end there are a lot of terms to
help define the year that was and google
has been keeping tabs on all of them
cataloging what millions of us looked up
or wanted to learn more about and as
jackson proskow explains the top
trending searches may explain some
surprises about ourselves
our screens are a window into who we are
and what we search for on our devices
reveals more than almost anything else
you're never as honest as you are with
your search engine we see this all the
time that people really search in ways
that you wouldn't necessarily want to do
like publicly on social media or
whatever this year google's top searches
suggest we're living in a moment of
uncertainty anxiety and genuine
curiosity
the top global search involved cricket
matches
the most searched news story was
afghanistan the most looked up people
were alec baldwin and kyle rittenhouse
and boy were there a lot of questions
about squid games
[Music]
and about bernie sanders mittens but
it's the questions people asked google
that perhaps said the most
canadians wondered why did prime
minister trudeau call an election why
were residential schools created and how
do i get a vaccine passport our american
cousin searched for the answers to
life's conundrums how to be more
attractive how to be romantic how to be
happy alone and you can really see this
kind of almost like desire to get back
to normal but to deal with the world
that we're faced with instead clearly
the pandemic had us searching for a way
out
where can i travel was a common query
the disappointing answer led people to
scour the internet for road trips
instead
while body positivity and mental health
garnered unprecedented interest it all
suggests there's a lot on our minds
things we're too embarrassed to ask
another human being
this complicated year has reminded us if
you don't know the answer you can always
just search for it
jackson prosko global news washington
or you can google it and that is global
national for this saturday night i'm
robin gill tonight your canada is city
hall in halifax decked out for the
holidays we would love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Music]
you